abschließende frage von englisch teils
willst du noch zu haben
kleine rennfahrer dem problem der brief
einfach btv weil ich habe daraus nicht
lange also mysterium gemacht aber jetzt
kann man die frage beantworten servus
skills bekommen zu einem neuen video
heute stehe ich vor einer wunderschönen
kölner hausfront ich bin heute am fall
nachdem köln gerade eben hier angekommen
morgen geht's weiter nach berlin zu
einer party
welches ist darf ich wahrscheinlich weil
ich alles sagen was ich will
aber ich sag es einfach nicht weil das
unnötig ihr habt mir auf twitter fragen
gestellt
unter dem hashtag was war es eigentlich
essen droht weil ich eigentlich dachte
dass ich dieses match auf der straße
machen würde also auf der autobahn
das war nicht der fall deswegen machen
wir das jetzt so ich habe hier auf
meinem wunderschönen iphone mit der
unbestellten hülle und dem
unbeschädigten apple-logo paar fragen
ausgesucht und wer ist immer eine frage
beantworten und dann die location
wechseln du hast was leichten einstieg
no place chris and play snowpark wie alt
bist du 19
willem svww fragt mit welchem auto fahrt
ihr und wem gehört das also erstmal will
begrüßt ich ihn kenne ich auch schon
sehr lange damals im urlaub
kennengelernt vor sechs jahren oder
sonst eine ewigkeit her ich bin mit
einer mitfahrgelegenheit nach köln
gekommen
was ich aber das kennt also es gibt so
eine seite mit verteidiger tut de da
sucht man halt ich will von nach köln
und denke das datum einen und dann
findet man da angebot wird recht günstig
oder gekommen also zweieinhalb stunden
fahrt 13 euro das ist okay
svenja apps veni unterstrich habe fragt
bist du eine eifersüchtige person
früher war das ganze bei mir früher war
ich echt da hatte ich viele viele fehler
und laster und alle gucken sind gucke
ich doch nicht so dumm an mein gott ich
hatte meine kamera vors gesicht als
würde ich im wald rumlaufen bist du eine
eifersüchtige person früher war es ganz
schlimm mittlerweile hat sich das
gebessert mittlerweile komme ich besser
damit klar würde ich sagen
ab und zu habe ich noch so leicht wie
sich die tendenzen aber es ist nicht
mehr ganz so wild game nato 1912 fragt
nächstes jahr wieder bürger battle mich
gerade eben echl drüber nachgedacht
ich weiß nicht also burbank auch viele
von der entscheidung des unternehmens ab
also mcdonald's noch weiterkommt von o2
wird das netz im nächsten jahr
wahrscheinlich noch besser klappen als
dieses jahr aber ich fühle mich
irgendwie nicht so wohl bei dem gedanken
hier auch schon drüber nachgedacht
nachdem ich bitte ausgeschieden bin
keine ahnung momentan würde ich eher zu
einem neuen tendiert
haye ist larissa fragt er der skate
zockt hast du einen traum bogen habe ich
tatsächlich ist kein klassischer beruf
aber mein traum was die berufliche
perspektive angeht wäre es selbstständig
zu sein als möchten selbständige
unternehmer sein
meine eigenes unternehmen haben und
damit erfolgreich sein das ist ein
bisschen ein traum weil sich ganz
finster wenig cool angestellt zu sein
das mag ich überhaupt nicht für diese
ganze herden dynamik in der belegschaft
an kollegen mit dem man sich verstehen
muss ich weiß nicht das nicht so nächste
frage von ed krims krams sarah krims
krams die fragt wie viele jahre sind
matt und du auseinander das sind
ziemlich genau eineinhalb jahre bis 1920
und max dieses monat ein 18
crazy unterstrich schicker unterstrich
park des checkers und rot was denkt /
würdest du denken wenn du siehst dass
ein verein sich jetzt mein erster
gedanke wäre ehrlich gesagt
wie kann ich die person helfen was kann
ich machen dass sie aufhört sich zu
schützen soll mein erster gedanke gar
nicht werten dass ich würde ich sagen oh
das ist schlecht oder die ist das blöd
oder was lockt mit der schiefen ich
würde sagen was kann ich machen dass sie
aufhört vorher ein fan sich jetzt
oftmals ein bisher noch irgendwie mit
dem fan tue man sich zusammen dass sie
damit irgendwie heraus stechen wollen
aus der masse der fans oder edel
beeindrucken wollen wir zeigen wie ernst
sie es meinen weiß nicht so ethnie drin
fragt was hast du beim
geschäftsessen mit matt gegessen sehr
gute frage wie können das ist wichtig
ich hab richtig gegessen wird mag ich
hab sogar am ende des trips zum kleinen
sushi smiley dagelassen dachte das wird
die leute verstehen war leider nicht der
fall
sehr lecker schnürsenkel fragt was
machst du in cologne city ich bin hier
einfach nur auf durchreise damit ich
morgen den shuttle der von hier nach
berlin fährt nehmen kann zu dieser party
und ich treffe mich eine rettung aber
welche wichtig dt
kräftig es mitnichten so war muss das
mal dezent in diesen müll container
versteckt muss aufpassen um die frei
nächste freude von krimskrams zu
beantworten die frage nämlich bist du
wirklich mit einem der zwei mädels aus
dem dörfchen tag zusammen finger bei
voller leute das ist die frage
weil das noch von ihm hören
man weiß es nicht
die leute gucken so behindert ach ja
übrigens noch bleibt william byrd ist er
gefragt mit welchem auto gefahren also
es war zwar nicht meint also gehörte dem
fahrer aber das war eine b klasse von
mercedes eine schwarze 140 ps diesel
muss man natürlich alles erfragen
damit wehrt xxxx fragt hate ist hat es
also mit einem thema das du als kind vor
etwas angst vor dem jetzt keine angst
mehr hass herz ps größte acer smartphone
sehr gut da die du bist echt auf der
richtigen seite
ich habe mir das gerade im schon
überlegt ich würde sagen die
wesentlichste sache vor ich meine angst
verloren hat sind albträume du frau
dunkelheit habe ich meine angst nicht
verloren würde ich sagen aber albträume
irgendwie wenn man als kind sieht man
die welt einfach noch viel naiver man
kann sich viel besser vorstellen dass es
solche monster wirklich gibt wenn man
irgendwann darüber nachdenkt was man
studieren will wo man sich
krankenversichert welche steuersatz man
hat dann keine ahnung
dann denkt man irgendwie nicht mehr
nicht ins schema teilen den monster
existieren bin ich deswegen glaube ich
verliere man so mit dem erwachsenwerden
also nicht das was gut das wäre so ist
denn dieses gefühl für irgendwen musik
oder besonders ausgefallener fantasie
sei schade durch diese hauseingang jetzt
jetzt zwei fragen von bettina pahn wenn
du magst in drei worten beschreiben
müsste ist welche wären es klammer auf
sorry aber die witze werden die
langweilig also die drei worte mit denen
ich mag's beschreiben würde wäre golden
ich sage ich einfach antwort oder
benotung wort weil der schweiz
verstanden aussagen so die abschließende
frage von frage von kies teils teils
abschließende frage von enkes teils bist
du noch zu haben
kleinere effekt im moment ist sie
vorgelesen ablief einfach wttv natürlich
ich habe daraus ein kleines mysterium
gemacht aber jetzt kann man die frage
beantworten ich bin momentan in keiner
beziehung ob das gleichzustellen es mit
zu haben ist die frage
aber es ist momentan auch wieder den
biss morden zschau